ion et non loin de saint pierre sur
dives dans le département voisin de la
seine maritime le vent mais aussi les
pluies qui ont accompagné la tempête ont
largement inondé vie des villages et
bien sûr et rivières sont en crue
plusieurs communes du pays de caux ne
disposent plus d'eau potable
sophie mais elle est christian l'euro
était aujourd'hui en seine maritime de
ce côté ci de la route
la mère a l'air presque paisible rien ne
trahit la détresse de la région 6e 17
bus qui les versent depuis 24 heures
sont au rang de murs à deux mètres de là
ces cabanons de vacances se vantait
naguère d'avoir les pieds dans l'eau ils
ont aujourd'hui peu fier à nous autres
nous ce sont les grosses marées alors du
fait que les grosses marées balle abusa
pas un débit qu'on dirait jeu comme
d'habitude donc là forcément valent
aussi accumulé ici derrière nous ba du
mal à partir puis sculpteront le
phénomène du gross marc ayrault tiens
justement ce début on venait dépendre le
fumier dans ce potager de la région de
dieppe
peine perdue les propriétaires sont en
vacances alors en leur absence la
solidarité s'organise comme il était pas
là toute la famille est venue pour lui
cette nuit tous les voisins sont venus à
quelques dizaines de kilomètres de là
sur la côte saint valery en caux reste
l'une des communes les plus touchées le
long de l'avenue carnot
toutes les familles ont tué
elle découvrait ce matin l'ampleur des
dégâts souvenirs détrempée que l'on n'a
pas encore le coeur de jeter il est
prévu de rentrer chez vous quand ben
prend l'ascendant au possible falloir
voir pour un appartement là plus rien la
patrie cité chauffage de yarakh
fonctionnent les meubles que ce soit les
habitants d'ici le savez un jour ou
l'autre le village serait inondé mais en
ce lendemain de noël préparé ou pas on a
du mal à se faire une raison